[Music]
jenner's going to do it he's won the
gold but he's going after the record
at the 1976 summer olympic games in
montreal
bruce later caitlyn jenner won gold
in the decathlon and became a household
name
wheaties has been on my breakfast table
since i was a kid and later that year
jenner received another coveted honor
being featured on a box of wheaties
cereal
scores of other top athletes have shared
that distinction
watch out big boys now with the tokyo
games entering their second week
will any current olympians be joining
them john nudi is the president
of north american retail at general
mills the maker of wheaties
is your marketing team currently
watching the olympics in tokyo to seek
out future box cover stars
clearly olympics are an exciting time in
sports so we're
certainly watching and seeing what's
happening over there and
which champions might emerge in the
history we use we actually have had over
70 olympians on the box
it's a big year for the cereal itself to
help give wheaties that sweet
rich taste the flakes that make up
wheaties were discovered
entirely by accident exactly 100 years
ago
why the whole family needs energy in
1921
a health clinician in minnesota spilled
a wheat bran mixture on a hot stove
and watched as it turned into a crispy
flake
tastes good too don't they he brought
his discovery to the predecessor of
general mills
who saw the potential for a new healthy
breakfast food
and in 1924 gold medal whole wheat
flakes
hit the market later renamed wheaties
early boxes featured a fictional
character named jack armstrong
but in 1934 the company switched to real
athletes
beginning with legendary yankee slugger
lou gehrig
the famous vaulting vicar robert
richards in the 1950s olympic pole
vaulter bob richards was the first to
move to the front of the box
one of over 850 athletes who've earned
the honor
from olympic stars like sean white and
apollo ono
to the winners of soccer's 2019 women's
world cup
to pro athletes like lebron james and
serena williams
only wheaties has tiger woods
makes the difference some sports
superstars like tiger woods and michael
phelps have appeared multiple times
today we welcome our newest champion but
the
all-time champ is michael jordan who's
shown up on 18
separate boxes how does general mills
choose the athletes they feature on
wheaties box covers you want great
athletes that's important
but champions are champions not only in
the ring or on the mat
they're champions of their communities
and around the world as well and now to
celebrate wheaties centennial
general mills has come up with their
century collector box series
the first will feature humanitarian and
boxing legend muhammad ali
[Music]
watch out big boys so they're going to
be three
other athletes you remember that gotcha
remember that
i don't know if that would fly these
days um
well that's a whole nother story but let
me tell you about this centennial it's
really interesting they're going to
unveil
three different box covers coming over
the next year it's part of their
centennial and really it is about
honoring recognizing people who are
making contributions beyond just their
individuals
so right now if you're talking about
wheaties box covers from this current
olympics you're looking at caleb dressel
right
right suny lee yes maybe katie ledecky
yes yes
there are a lot of story lines coming
out of tokyo so it'll be really
interesting yeah and unexpected ones
unexpected apologies if i forgot anyone
but it's fun to watch